eine woche lang verschwundene spurlos
und jetzt jetzt ist es traurige
gewissheit die 14 jahre alte josephine
aus aschersleben wurde getötet und der
mutmaßliche mörder ihr 14 jähriger ex
freund in einer garage auf einem
garagenhof lag ihre leiche früh deutet
viel auf den 14 jährigen hin die beiden
hatten sich am tag von josef ines
verschwinden zu einer aussprache
getroffen und lautem jungen
freundschaftlich getrennt eine lüge ja
was für ein mordfall eine 14-jährige
wird getötet offenbar von einem anderen
team ii einem ebenfalls 14 jährigen er
war erster liebe offenbar über diesen
fall wollen wir sprechen mit unserem
bild reporter thilo scholtyseck der
genau dort ist die lovis solche von
josefine gefunden wurde nach einer woche
die man josephine als vermisst gemeldet
hatte sie gesucht hatte ein teenie 14
tötet einen anderen teenie 14 was kannst
du aktuell über den mutmaßlichen mördern
in ex freund von josefine sagen
gut morgen ja wir sind hier am tatort
den garagenkomplex wo die leiche am
mittwoch gefunden wurde der der täter
wurde danach von der polizei mit dem
leichenfund konfrontiert und hat spontan
die tat auch eingeräumt zu dem jungen
muss man sagen es ist ein 14-jähriger
schüler er besuchte dieselbe schule wie
sein opfer die beiden waren ein paar
monate liiert er ist eigentlich ein
völlig unauffälliger junger er wird als
guter schüler beschrieben er war bei der
freiwilligen feuerwehr nicht auffällig
nachbarn sagen höflich zuvorkommend
gab keine anzeigen bei der polizei und
ganz im gegenteil dann seine reaktion im
verhör dazu völlig emotionslos reagiert
haben er hat noch gebeten dass seine
eltern rausgeschickt werden die waren
beim verhör anfangs mit dabei und dann
hat er eingeräumt dass es spontan ein
grund das ist eine spontane tat war
keine entführung keine spontane tat war
sondern es geplant hat dass er sie
eigentlich bewusstlos schlagen wollte
und dann letztlich getötet hat
die tatwaffe das messer ist auch
sichergestellt worden was weißt du über
das motiv
ja zum motiv weiß aber mittlerweile dass
er mit schüler einen mitschüler gesagt
hat er sei genervt von von josiah wollte
das nicht mehr war ihr überdrüssig so
muss man das wirklich sagen und später
hat er sogar noch eine einer eine
whatsup nachricht an einen komplizen
abgesetzt in der einfach geschrieben hat
jetzt nervt sie nicht mehr und das ist
natürlich besonders kaltblütig der
komplize übrigens hat hier auch im
garagenkomplex mit schmiere gestanden
aber die polizei kann ihnen keine
unmittelbare tatbeteiligung nachweisen
weshalb er auch nicht in haft genommen
wurde der täter selber sitzt jetzt in
der jugendhaftanstalt in rassen jetzt in
sachsen anhalt wie ist das mit einer
strafe für einen so jungen für einen 14
jahre alten täter killer muss man ja
sagen wenn das auch noch eine geplante
tat war der junge mann der jugendliche
das ist ja fast ein kind also was kommt
er möglicherweise für eine strafe auf
ihn zu
ja wie gesagt der täter ist
14 jahre alt damit ist das strafmündig
er wird nach jugendstrafrecht verurteilt
werden das jugendstrafrecht sieht für
totschlag mord als höchststrafe zehn
jahre vor wenn er die tat gesteht müsste
ein geständnis ich ihm auch noch
strafmildernd angerechnet werden das
wird sich dann im laufe der ermittlungen
zeigen man wird ihn natürlich auch
psychiatrisch begutachten ob vielleicht
auch sogar eine unterbringung in einer
anstalt in frage kommt dann kann unseren
bild-reporter thilo scholtyseck dort in
aschersleben vor dieser garage in der
die leiche von josefine gefunden wurde
nach dem ja und mittlerweile hat eben
ihre mutmaßliche mörder ihr ex-freund
ihre erste liebe diese tat gestanden
danke team ein teenie tötet einen
anderen teenie das ist nicht das erste
mal dass wir über solche teenie morde
berichten in den vergangenen monaten
immer wieder allein in diesem jahr sind
drei weitere solche morde passiert die
uns so fassungslos machen auch weil die
täter ebenso junge hier passierte so
etwas im nobelviertel bogenhausen in
münchen
die 14 jahre alte leila wird im schlaf
von ihrem 17 jahre alten ex freund mit
einem stich ins herz einem stich getötet
heimtückisch der mutmaßliche mörder der
schweigt bis heute aber auch dass eine
teenie tat einen monat vorher im
september 20 21 ein 15 jähriger sticht
brutal auf die auch erst 16 jahre alte
victoria mit einem messer an ihre leiche
findet man dann wie die von josefine in
einem garagenhof gut eine woche später
wird hier der 15 jahre alte killer
festgenommen täter und opfer kannten
sich auch in diesem fall und im februar
dieses jahres erschüttert eine tat den
ort sinsheim in baden württemberg ein 14
jähriger tötet da den 13 jahre alten
sinan aus eifersucht mit mehreren
messerstichen also drei solcher taten in
münchen in sinsheim jetzt in
aschersleben teenies töten teenies ein
phänomen dieser zeit möglicherweise
schreckliche taten unter jugendlichen